the justice department is investigating
the shooting as a hate crime and a
racially motivated event violent
extremism being the cause we're also
learning more about the suspect payton
gendron authorities say he threatened a
shooting at his high school outside
binghamton new york nearly a year ago
jeff begays has more now on the ongoing
investigation and prosecution
wearing a paper gown and mask 18 year
old peyton gendron was arraigned over
the weekend for the shooting deaths of
at least 10 people at a top supermarket
in a predominantly black community we
continue to investigate this case
as a hate crime a federal hate crime and
as a crime perpetrated by a racially
motivated motivated violent extremist
gendron has been charged with first
degree murder and is likely to face
federal hate crime and domestic terror
charges
investigators say he plotted the attack
over several months allegedly posting a
180 page manifesto online
he described himself as a white
supremacist and anti-semite and refer to
the racist idea known as replacement
theory the notion that white americans
are at risk of being replaced by people
of color this is a very urgent threat in
fact we're seeing the fbi and law
enforcement move resources away from say
isis and al qaeda cases on to white
supremacy cases extremist experts say
that he is part of an alarming spike in
white supremacists and domestic
terrorist activities online there's a
sense of community online that that eggs
them on that encourages them to do this
and they use what they learn online to
go on to the physical world and kill
people
new york state officials say that
gendron had threatened a shooting at his
high school last year the individual was
brought in for a mental health
evaluation he was evaluated and then he
was released the suspect was never
flagged as an extreme risk under the
state's red flag law that could have
prevented him from purchasing a gun
under the state's red flag law certain
individuals whether it be family members
or law enforcement if they believe that
someone is a threat to the community can
go to a judge petition that judge to
issue what's called an extreme risk
protection order according to our
sources in this case that didn't happen
the suspect is being held here he's on
suicide watch he's being held without
bail his next court appearance is
scheduled for thursday tony
begets for us jeff thank you very much